Hey so okay ah this is I don't know I
was just sitting here trying to some
email and the anxiety hit I like sitting
at my desk and I'm looking around under
just quartz like quartz quartz quartz
quartz quartz course everywhere plugged
in give me the cord for everything like
a USB card it is emitting you need a
micro you need a lightning cable yeah I
need a power cord core just look at this
huh when you take a little gander a
little peek a little peek if you will
chords chords we've hit the mother lode
Paul oh goodness you try to hide the
cores didn't hide them very well yoga
blocks chords so gays
let's thank you back here hit the shot
chords oh you are these mark words I'm
standing at my desk
zoom in chords chords chords court good
I think I had a little coffee this
morning
go play chords I need you I need you but
I don't like you look bedroom chords
course what chords and my blood pressure
because I like I take my blood pressure
or nowhere today let's take it now
should we take my blubbers you're not
which arm do I put you on towards
soldier towards hand my normal resting
heart rate is usually like 63 92 92 you
know why you know what it's got me all
high-strung carbs let's go find some
more shall we
I wanna go for a ride to happy Thursday
Jay's Thursday maybe it's Thursday
I don't know sometimes YouTube doesn't
like to push the videos out when I say
hey post ho what do we have here Hey
that's it the end of the video let me
know what annoys you guys because what
annoys me is of course I love you I'll
see you soon